in diesem video geht es um die
gestaffelte aussaat beziehungsweise die
gestaffelte ernte das ist eigentlich das
ziel das man im gemüsegarten nicht
einmal eine riesengroße erntemenge hat
die einen erschlägt wo man überhaupt
nicht mehr weiß wohin mit dem ganzen
gemüse sondern regelmäßig kleine mengen
ernten kann so quasi wie man ganz normal
in den laden geht und sich die sachen
einkauf da würde man ja auch nicht so
ein berg salat auf einmal nehmen sondern
gerne jede woche ein 23 köpfe je nachdem
wie viel salat man gerne ist und da geht
es glaube ich ganz vielen gemüsegarten
anfängern so ähnlich wie mir am anfang
nämlich dass es gar nicht so einfach ist
festzulegen wann man denn wie viel
gemüse aussehen muss und wieder die
abstände zwischen den einzelnen sätzen
sein müssen beziehungsweise wie man das
überhaupt hinkriegt und darum geht es in
diesem video wir machen also weiter mit
der anbauplanung ich habe ja letzte
woche ein video veröffentlicht so
anbauplanung dass ich gerade eben
gedreht habe und ich habe gemerkt ich
muss noch zur gestaffelten ernte noch
einfach noch ein paar wörtchen verlieren
um euch das besser erklären zu können
also schaut euch zuerst das andere video
an wenn ihr gerade an euren pflanzplan
knobelt das ist unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und jetzt geht es
weiter genau festzulegen also
detaillierter in dem plan einzusteigen
und zu schauen was sind denn die besten
außer termine für welches gemüse und wie
kriege ich das hin
die beete das ganze jahr über so zu
nutzen dass dann auch eine gestaffelte
ernte dabei rauskommt wir haben ja eben
schon unserem wunschzettel stellt das
heißt du hast wenn du das andere video
geschaut hast können die ganze liste mit
den gemüsen erstellt die du in diesem
jahr anbauen möchte ist und jetzt gilt
es erstmal festzulegen welchen gemüsen
es denn sinnvoll ist eine gestaffelte
auszumachen und bei welchen eher nicht
und ich mache das so dass ich vor allem
die wurzelgemüse und die blattgemüse
also zb karotten rote beete radieschen
oder bei den blattgemüse salat spinat
oder mangold gestaffelt aussehe so dass
ich da regelmäßig etwas ernte oder auch
kohlgemüse zähle ich auch zu dem
blattgemüse zumindest so was wie rotkohl
oder weißkohl so dass wir davon einfach
regelmäßig etwas aus dem garten ernten
können
zum beispiel bei tomaten mache ich das
nicht weil das ja eine pflanze ist wo
man nicht die pflanze selbst erntet wie
zb die karotte die man aus dem boden
zieht und dann hat man die in der hand
und da wächst nichts mehr nach oder den
salatkopf die man abschneidet darauf
kommen übrigens auch noch gleich zu
sprechen dass man das bei blattgemüse ja
auch anders machen kann dass man das ja
mehrfach beenden kann
aber im grunde erntet man schon die
ganze pflanze und nicht nur einen teil
wie zb die tomate die frucht die man
abnimmt und die pflanze produziert
weiter munter früchte vor sich hin das
heißt bei dem ganzen fruchtgemüse wie zb
tomaten kürbis und so weiter mache ich
das nicht bei paprika und auberginen
weil die pflanzen immer weiter laufend
früchte produzieren wenn ich bei
fruchtgemüse der gestaffelte ausland
mache dann nur bei gurken und zucchini
bei den anderen aber überhaupt nicht und
es bezieht sich vielmehr auf die
wurzelgemüse und die blattgemüse so dass
man da in den laufenden bedarf werden
kann weil die frucht gemüse machen das
schon ganz gut von selber da kannst du
dir jetzt einfach mal die liste mit den
gemüsen die duh anbauen möchtest
durchgehen und diejenigen bei denen eine
gestaffelte aussaat sinnvoll ist mal
einfach in einer farbe markieren sodass
du das auf einen blick sehen kannst und
um festzulegen welches gemüse denn wie
lange braucht bis es dann geerntet
werden kann so dass man das überhaupt
planen kann ministern aussehen muss und
wie oft nehme ich mir jetzt mal wie ein
saatgut tütchen weil da steht ja oft
darauf wann es gesät wird und wann es
geerntet werden kann und in dem fall ist
das jetzt hier ein salat den soll man
zwischen februar und april aussehen und
dann kann man ihn zwischen mai und juli
ehren der braucht drei monate bis man in
erden kann also von der ersten auszeit
bis zur ersten ernte vergehen drei
monate das team eine super gute auskunft
für unsere planung weil wir dann sagen
können
okay wir brauchen jeden monat kann man
dann bei so grob schätzen dann viel
bedarf eure familie dann überhaupt h wir
haben dazu listen so dass wir das jedes
jahr eigentlich schon von vorneherein
wissen ich mach dazu noch ein video
wahrscheinlich nächste oder übernächste
woche sodass ihr planen können wie viel
gemüse ihr denn pro person im haushalt
anbauen könnten wenn man das grob ihr
könnt ja mal über
wie viel salat essen wir denn pro woche
vielleicht drei köpfe wie viele ich so
einkaufen wenn ich das noch nicht selber
im garten anbauen und dann könnt ihr
schauen dass wenn jede woche ebenso
viele köpfe reif werden und es ist auch
so dass man die gemüse nicht nur eine
woche lang ernten kann also bei den
allermeisten gemüsen ist das ernte
fenster viel größer also dass man da
eben schon planen kann dass man zb den
gesamten salat wie man in einem monat
essen mag also sagen wir jetzt mal den
gesamten salat für den monat mai den man
jetzt gerade aussehen kann ihn bauen wir
dann zum beispiel gesammelt an also
jetzt sehe ich allen salat den ich ihr
mal ernten möchte und nächsten monat
sehe ich einen salat den ich im juni
ernten möchte weil zum beispiel ja man
kann ja auch kleinere köpfe ernten oder
kurs größere köpfe und bei salat ist
auch noch das tolle dass der wieder
nachwächst wenn man ihn über dem boden
ab schneidet das heißt man kann das
ernte fenster auch noch weiter strecken
so dass es zum beispiel auch möglich
wäre den salat nur alle zwei monate aus
zusehen wenn man den so erntet dass er
wieder austreibt nur irgendwann gehen
die pflanzen dann in die blüte so dass
man das nicht endlos ausreizen kann
dabei salat ist das nicht ganz so
einfach aber ihr könnt ungefährlich
hauspflege mitnehmt als ihr bei so
zarten blattgemüse für alle vier bis
sechs wochen eine neue aussaat machen
müsst damit ihr laufend mit dem gemüse
versorgt seit bei wurzelgemüse wie zum
beispiel der karotte ist es nicht ganz
so einfach da eine faustregel
festzulegen weil die sehr
unterschiedlich sind das heißt wenn zb
eine schnell wachsende karotten sorte
die sorte gonsenheimer treibt die sehr
schnell die ersten karotten liefert die
dafür nicht besonders lang sind aber
macht ja nichts wenn man dafür schneller
eine ernte bekommt und eine langsam
wachsende hre lager sorte die natürlich
viel länger braucht bis sie dann
irgendwann ernte bereit ist also immer
auch auf die sorten achten die man
anbaut und immer auf die saatgut tütchen
schauen so dass ihr dafür jedes gemüse
puzzeln könnt welche außer zeit punkte
denn wann sinnvoll sind und ihr habt ja
in den letzten video schon den
pflanzplan heruntergeladen
das ist ein clown mit sechs großen
beeten wo man schon eine ganze menge
ernten
und wo die gestaffelte aussaat auch
schon berücksichtigt ist also schaut
euch den gerne an wenn ihr es noch nicht
gemacht habt der link ist nochmal unten
in der video beschreibung da müsst ihr
dann gar nicht mehr viel anpassen weil
ich den eben schon ausgeknobelt habe und
schon dafür gesorgt habe dass man mit
dem plan laufend das ganze jahr über aus
dem garten ernten kann aber manchmal
will man ja eher schwer man nämlich
genau dann wenn es an das haltbarmachen
geht viele gemüse jetzt nicht unbedingt
salat aber so ziemlich alle anderen
gemüse kann man ja haltbar machen und
das ist eine ganz wichtige aufgabe im
sommer damit man im winter eben auch
noch aus dem eigenen garten essen kann
und deswegen weil es haltbar machen auch
für uns super wichtig und elementar ist
und wenn es das auch ganz viel spaß
bringt berücksichtige ich das immer in
meiner anbauplanung indem ich mir
überlege zum beispiel wenn ich
sauerkraut machen möchte da will ich
gerne an einem tag das ganze sauerkraut
ansetzen dass wir für ein jahr brauchen
und da müssen schon einige kohlköpfe her
damit dass dann auch klappt das heißt
ich plane jetzt schon ich weiß genau
welche weißkohl sollte sich für
sauerkraut am besten eignet das ist
übrigens die domina die wir gerne
anbauen für den sauerkraut für die
sauerkraut produktion und von der plane
ich immer einen richtig großen satz und
das ist jetzt nur ein beispiel von
vielen so dass wir im sommer dann
hingehen können und ganz viel auf einmal
haltbar machen können und sich das nicht
ewig schleppt sondern wir das bündeln
können und zb an einem tag das ganze
sauerkraut machen an einem tag karotten
und ärzten zusammen ein kochen und alle
sachen herstellen die wir eben brauchen
damit wir unsere vorrats regale damit
fühlen können also dass auch immer mit
beachten wenn ihr lust habt im sommer
haltbar zu machen und im winter immer
noch einen richtig schönen vollen
vorratsschrank vorzufinden nicht findet
das gerade so schön da die ganzen
schätze auf zu machen die wir im sommer
haltbar gemacht haben und es ist auch
eine große wertschätzung die man das
spürt finde ich weil ich genau weiß wie
sie arbeit dar eingeschlossen ist ist
einfach ein super schönes gefühl und
deswegen achtet darauf dass ihr das
jetzt schon ein
damit es dann auch klappt genauso wäre
dass zb bei den kartoffeln
da wollen wir auch nicht ständig
irgendwie neue kartoffeln aus dem boden
ausgaben sondern einmal alle aus dem
boden raus holen
alle abtrocknen lassen auf dem bett und
dann einlagern so dass wir das an einem
tag erledigt haben und nicht ständig
immer wieder kartoffeln ernten müssen
außer natürlich bei den frühkartoffeln
also das variiert immer ein bisschen wir
bauen natürlich auch weißkohl angehen
wie vorher schon ernten und haben damit
einer anderen sorte nämlich mit der
sorte nagels verweist die sehr schnell
schöne köpfe bildet aber sich nicht so
gut für sauerkraut eignet immer noch
mehr gestaffelte aus also dass wir die
regelmäßig ernten können und mit den
frühkartoffeln auch die entweder noch
laufend immer wenn wir lust haben frisch
aus dem bäder schmiegen sie am besten
oder aber eben nicht bei dem lager
kartoffeln nur nicht bei dem weißkohl
den wir zum haltbarmachen verwenden
möchten und so kann man das gefalle
gemüse die man zum haltbarmachen anbaut
eben auch übertragen aber bevor ihr
jetzt eure satz planung macht schaut
euch auf jeden fall das video oder
trüben an wo ich über die anbau planten
spreche und alle schritte die man vorher
machen sollte mit euch durch fouls so
dass am ende dann der fertige an bauplan
studio für alle die es so weit geschafft
haben